cuando fue la última vez que el rey
stage pero de verdad
de esas veces que te ríes te duele la
barriga lloras de la risa y no puedes
parar de reír
si tenéis que pensarlo tanto es que hace
mucho
ahora que tenéis el momento
donde estabais con quién estabais
estabais solos o con gente probablemente
estaríais con amigos porque la risa es
mucho mejor cuando es compartida por ese
punto de función social de conexión
emocional que tiene la risa si lo
pensáis la risa es algo privativo y
diferencial del ser humano porque somos
los únicos animales que podemos reírnos
a excepción de los simios y de las
hienas me diréis sí pero ellos se ríen
de otra manera y es que el humor está
relacionado íntimamente con la evolución
humana con la bipedestación cuando nos
pusimos de pie y el tórax se expandió
para respirar mejor
la risa ha estado estudiada desde la
antigüedad desde aristóteles y platón
con sus comedias sobre el ridículo
pasando por hobbes kant schopenhauer ya
en 1983 bears ton atribuye a la risa esa
función social es decir que el ser
humano como animal social que es como
animal social que somos nos relacionamos
a través de elementos humorísticos y eso
qué quiere decir pues que la risa nos
libera nos hace sentir cómplices
inteligentes mejor y eso la industria
cultural lo sabe el cine la televisión
la publicidad ya habían utilizado el
humor como estrategia para esa conexión
emocional que comentábamos al principio
de unión entre las personas
probablemente habréis visto esta campaña
de netflix
para anunciarla a la serie sex education
y los que no ya estais esbozando una
sonrisa porque ese es el poder
maravilloso que tiene la risa de
conectar a las personas pero el humor
también tiene otra serie de
características como por ejemplo
minimizar la percepción de violencia es
decir este es el quid de la cuestión de
las pelis de cine mudo que si lo penséis
había muchísima violencia caídas peleas
y entonces parecía muy divertido en la
actualidad por ejemplo tendríamos rasca
y pica de los simpson que un ratón y un
gato no hace más que el zorro asen hoy y
molerse a palos y nos parece divertido
porque con la risa prácticamente se
puede comunicar todo además
el humor desmonta las defensas de
nuestro receptor con humor se puede
comentar prácticamente de todo por
ejemplo en una discusión cuando nuestro
interlocutor está como enfadadísimo si
alguien es lo suficientemente paciente e
inteligente como bajar el tono contestar
con humor o con ironía es muy complicado
que siga escalando el nivel de la
conversación simplemente porque
desmontamos al interlocutor además al
principio os preguntaba si recordáis la
carita de la persona con quién estaba
cuando reid y problema pues
probablemente sea así porque el humor
tiene el poder de anclar la emoción a
nuestro recuerdo
por no hablar de que el humor también
hace visibles los tabúes nos podemos
reír del sexo de la muerte aquí por
ejemplo vemos a la pantera rosa' que se
le ha complicado la noche
nunca me ha pasado
se le ha complicado a la noche y nos
parece divertido aquí podría subir y
hacer perfectamente un tabú social como
es el alcoholismo si sustituimos el
peluche rosa por una persona sin hogar
qué pasa aquí noche tras noche que está
su realidad ya deja de ser divertido
porque con risa y con humor se puede
hablar prácticamente de todo porque la
risa nos libera quien no ha contado un
chiste por ejemplo en una reunión para
romper el hielo o nos hemos sorprendido
a nosotros mismos contando un chiste o
riéndonos en tierra un familiar
para
a llevar un poquito la tensión y
momentáneamente el dolor no
entonces si hemos visto que el humor
funciona funciona en el plano teórico en
el plano empírico porque en la vida real
nos reímos tampoco
los expertos comentan que los niños
pueden reírse de media hasta 400 veces
al día
mientras que los adultos apenas unas 80
qué nos ha pasado
cuando de repente nos hemos vuelto
nosotros estos adultos ridículamente
ocupados ridículamente absurdos que no
tenemos tiempo ni para reírnos
quizá deberíamos aprender de
y esos pequeños locos bajitos' habréis
visto con vuestros hijos nuestros
sobrinos cuando vais a un bar oa un
parque se encuentran dos niños y qué
ocurre
amor infinito se convierten en amigos
instantáneos eso los adultos nosotros no
hemos perdido cuando nos invitan una
fiesta que es lo primero que decimos
quién va
pero como que tiempo porque cuanta más
gente mejor o al menos ese debería ser
el espíritu porque conocer a gente nueva
debería ser la savia que alimentará a
nuestras neuronas y nuestras vidas tener
conversaciones interesantes
si es con una sonrisa mejor sobre todo
teniendo en cuenta las bondades los
pequeños milagros que una sonrisa puede
obrar en nuestra cara como por ejemplo
ser percibidos como más bellos caer
mejor o incluso ser mejor retribuidos se
calcula que las personas que son
percibidas como más bellas o que son más
extrovertidas pueden llegar a ganar
hasta un 11% más por el denominado
efecto beer y premium
no hablar de que el sentido del humor es
una de los rasgos de la personalidad más
apreciados a la hora de buscar pareja no
tanto que nos hagan reír y que nos
digamos que también si no compartir el
mismo código
las personas tenemos un termómetro un
barómetro interno que mide el humor que
técnicamente se llama ene efe h on it
for human y que mide la capacidad que
tenemos de recibir humor de tolerarlo y
de producirlo y lo maravilloso es que
cada uno de nosotros tenemos un nivel
distinto por eso es tan importante que a
la hora de encontrar nuestra pareja
nuestros amigos definitiva nuestra tribu
tengamos esa misma frecuencia de onda y
podamos decodificar
eso que nos están contando porque en
definitiva el humor no es más que una
broma privada que sólo dos personas
pueden entender y que nos hace
cosquillas en la mente y en el corazón
porque el humor es también un gran
pegamento social en las relaciones
íntimas incluso las personas que ríen
juntas las parejas que ríen juntas duran
más
quizás porque compartan ese código esa
frecuencia ese nfc que hablábamos pero
también porque comparten una serie de
valores y porque comparten un modo de
ver la vida así que sí como hemos visto
el amor el humor es positivo para en el
ámbito social porque la risa nos libera
nos hace sentir cómplices más
inteligentes mejor si es positivo en el
ámbito laboral porque nos hace
relativizar los problemas socializarnos
e incluso nos beneficia a nuestra
carrera profesional y en el ámbito
emocional y amatorio las parejas que
ríen juntas avanzan más tiempo más lejos
y mejor
el humor sale definitivamente a cuenta
así que si me permitís para acabar
simplemente un consejo personal
que hagáis mucho el humor porque sonreír
siempre es una buena idea gracias
[Aplausos]